it is decision day for embattled chinese
property developer evergrand
after expanding rapidly for years and
building an empire that goes far beyond
real estate the company is on the brink
of collapse evergrande is under crushing
debt of more than
300 billion dollars it's borrowed
aggressively to build out an empire of
skyscrapers hotels electric car
factories food and drink processing
plants it even owns guangzhou football
club now today could be crucial for the
company avogrant has said it will make
an interest payment worth 36 million u.s
dollars
to chinese investors but that's just one
payment due it also owes foreign
investors
over
84 million u.s dollars in interest
evergrande hasn't said if it will make
the payment here's more
in hong kong evergrand chairs have
jumped almost 20 percent after the
troubled property giant had struck an
agreement with chinese bondholders the
announcement helped calm some investor
concerns but the world's most indebted
developer still has to make a 84 million
dollars interest payment on an overseas
bond on thursday
in exchange for more time to solve its
internal problems
evergreen desperately needs to raise
cash to pay off at least some of its 300
billion dollar debt load
and it does have a sprawling list of
assets more than a thousand real estate
projects across china an electric
vehicle maker and even a soccer team
i can see it being chopped up either
sold off piece by piece
something will be arranged
it's a matter of how long the chinese
government's going to let this process
play out
evergrand home buyers and contractors
have protested recently at the company's
headquarters in shenzhen
they say they want their money back
so do thousands of investors around the
world
let's talk more about this with my
colleagues christy platson in frankfurt
and clifford coonan here in the studio
clifford let me start with you how much
time has this latest repayment bought
the company um it's bought them some
time but you sort of feel somehow that
this is like a very small part of what
is a much much more serious problem um
it's we're talking about
29 of chinese gdp is based on real
estate evergrande is one of the biggest
of those um and then it's coming out
with this very small measure and um i
think in real terms it's just going to
buy them a very small amount of time but
they've got much more much deeper issues
to address much deeper issues to address
nevertheless christie platson and
frankfurt i'm guessing markets are
breathing a sigh of relief here
well there does seem to be consensus
that we are going to avoid a worst case
scenario in this situation
a week ago we were talking a lot about
this being china's layman brothers
moment more and more people are saying
that won't be the case and so this has
certainly had a soothing effect on
markets
as we just heard they have reached an
agreement for for an initial payment the
details of that are unclear but that
does seem to have uh have calmed down
the markets to some degree
clifford over to you um what is the
government's reaction to this we know
that a lot of other chinese real estate
companies are also highly indebted could
the government step in here
yeah i mean property is just and real
estate is it's so important a part of
the chinese economy and you know the
market has grown like crazy for 25 years
we've never had really any price falls
in china so the government is clearly
worried about what's going on but how
they'll intervene is harder to say i
think it's going to be kind of a mixed
bag of measures that they'll put a
little bit of pressure on the state
banks here and there they'll give some
kind of fudge to the overseas lenders
and it'll be very difficult to see from
outside i mean we've had no indications
in the chinese state media for example
about any of this so um we're really
looking into a black box but um i think
the government will intervene but it'll
be in a very in very sort of subtle and
mixed ways
uh christie in in frankfurt uh back to
you um evergrande owes more than 80
million dollars in interest to foreign
investors how likely is it that the
company will make this payment
well chris i think we have to take a
kind of a larger look at the situation
here i mean we have that that 84 million
in interest but if we look at the
overall debt of this company we're
talking about over 300 billion dollars
in in overall debt and of that debt only
about 20 billion is to international
creditors so it does seem that domestic
uh domestic debt is more pressing for
evergrand right now though of course we
do have this international bond coming
due today but
as we said before they do seem to be uh
you know reaching some sort of
negotiations to handle these payments
what exactly that means we don't know
for national markets what is maybe more
significant now that we know that we
most likely won't be seeing a systemic
uh you know crash of the chinese economy
really it's just like clifford was
talking about we're seeing a a sort of
new
style of intervention from the
government after years of just colossal
largely unregulated growth from these
markets and a lot of international
players had really seen this as a future
sort of investment
strategy china so this is a big change
for those markets
clifford back to you
a lehman-like crash uh
may have been avoided here but
nevertheless what is the impact of all
this on the chinese economy well um i
think it's interesting i mean you know
we we're talking about i mean everground
is three percent the debts are about
three percent of the chinese economy
it's a huge amount and i think that um
i i think the the effect overall effect
in the chinese economy we become kind of
addicted to uninterrupted
chinese growth and i think that that
situation is slightly changing now
people are starting to ask deeper and
more penetrating questions about what's
actually going on in the chinese economy
and we've been talking about lehman
brothers in the parallel there with
evergrand but maybe people are going to
start asking questions about who's too
big to fail here is it is it evergrand
or is it the communist party itself that
may be too big to fail
clifford conan and christie plattson in
frankfurt thanks to both of you
you